I'm a professional MMA fighter when a record of far and 1:00 AM I'm an up and
coming fighter and without a doubt you will see me on the UFC in the near
future.
Last year
I knew I was going to be the person to bring martial arts in the public eye.
I know it's happening.
You know what I mean?
There's two things I've learned from all from these past seven months.
Number one is the hard work pays off and number two is that dreams come true.
If you go up to 100 people and ask them what they really want out of life,
98 of them won't be able to tell you.
Yeah.
You'll get a lot of answers like,
oh,
I just want to be happy,
or I just want to be able to do what I love,
but most of them won't be able to give any concrete form to what they want and
they definitely won't be able to give even the slightest indication of a plan to
get it.
Yeah,
so it's all I do.
I train twice a day.
That's all I think about.
It's just I don't want to do anything else.
It's as simple as that.
My dream was to be world champion.
The lightweight champion in the UFC have mom will need to have,
I know what to deal with and have a great low for me,
my kids,
my grandkids,
everyone in my,
in my family,
everyone that's come up with me.
That's my dream.
Back when Conor McGregor was first pursuing his love of mixed martial arts,
he was told countless times how impractical it was.
No Man from Ireland had ever made it to the highest levels of fighting.
What made him think that he could be the first,
but Connor didn't care.
He not only knew exactly what he wanted,
but he carried himself like he already had it.
In his mind,
the goal was already a wedding.
His claim,
he just had to execute so we could go and take it.
His desire was so strong at forced him to take continuous action towards his
goals,
not knowing what one wants in life is one of the major causes of failure.
If you don't know what you want,
how can you ever expect to get it?
If you don't write down your goals,
your just living in this wishy washy world of,
Oh,
I just want to be happy.
There's never anything concrete that you can grasp onto action will always be
more valuable than theory.
Halfheartedly wishing and hoping for something we'll never be as effective as
taking direct action.
And yes,
writing down what you want is the first and the easiest to action to take.
But by doing this,
you've just taken the first step to coaxing your idea into the physical world.
Connor did this by vividly imagining himself in a better life and carrying
himself like he already had that life.
And he still does this today vividly.
Imagining not only his victories,
but also the challenges he will face and what he will do to overcome them.
Yeah,
true.
Oh,
training camp,
you definitely have shots that you see,
that you feel cracking.
You know,
you've,
you'll feel them shots happen,
you know.
Um,
but this is,
this is,
trust me,
this is a first round k over me.
I've no doubt on my mind,
his,
his toes will curl and I will celebrate
hands in his hands
if he's,
if he shows up,
I feel hell.
Okay.
I'll him inside.
Warning if he may start walking to be is in the octagon.
I feel every single,
every single movement I make,
we'll get an overreaction off of him cause he's emotionally invested in it.
This June.
What Jane in front of me.
Gotcha.
How do you do that
is you can see it here and you have the courage enough to speak it.
It will happen.
Another one of the most common causes of failure is the habit of quitting.
When someone is taken by temporary defeat.
Connor was on the verge of giving up,
fighting for good.
When he finally got the call to fight for the UFC,
imagine how different his life would be if he stopped three feet short of
striking gold,
and this happens in all walks of life.
It seems like there is an invisible guide that tests people through all sorts of
discouraging experiences to see you is truly worthy of success.
Persistence knows no such thing as failure.
Okay.
Connor woke up at 5:00 AM every morning.
We're 10 to 12 hours a day as a plumber and then went immediately to training at
night.
This was taken an incredible toll on his body and he was faced with the choice.
He quit plumbing and focused on training full time despite many heated arguments
with his parents.
Okay.
Burning the boats is a popular self improvement topic.
You burn the boats and get rid of all forms of retreat,
so now you are forced to succeed.
Okay.
Many people talk about burning the boats,
but they forget the element of taking action.
Cool.
You burnt the boats,
you are not guaranteed success and you will fail if you don't hustle towards
your dreams.
Imagine if at the signing of the Declaration of Independence,
Thomas Jefferson,
John Hancock,
and everyone else who signed their name said,
okay,
we just burned the boats and now we can't fail.
They knew if they didn't win the head just signed their death warrant.
They gave themselves no choice but to devote all their energy into winning their
freedom.
Okay,
I will.
Oh,
you will be where I want to be.
I mean,
I'm really,
I'm 100% confident that I,
that I will make it to the top.
I have the scales,
I have the dedication and it's something I really,
really want to.
Boards boards can't even describe,
but it will happen.
I let you know when it happens.
I feel to be at the pinnacle on money game in any whatever you do,
you've got to be a little bit gone to it.
You're not all there.
You've got to be almost insane,
Tia.
Craft,
not a lot of people can understand that.
That's why I don't know about nothing else.
I do not pay attention to not announced.
What happens if you do lose to Josie elder.
That is not in the equation.
That does not processing my brain for one second.
Connor was 15 when he experienced a life changing moment.
He moved from his hometown in Crumlin to a quiet neighborhood on the outskirts
of Dublin.
The move toward him,
away from his lifelong friends and put them in a place full of people he didn't
know.
As a teenager.
He did not handle this very well,
but it set the stage for his deep visualization that he credits for his success.
He said,
I feel being alone with your thoughts is a good thing.
It allows you to figure things out for yourself.
Thinking is one of the hardest jobs you will ever do.
Tear someone away from their cell phone and make them sit in a room with just
their thoughts for eight hours and they will freak out.
It was around this time of deep introspection that Connor first started to
develop.
Napoleon hill calls a money consciousness.
He refused to accept a life without riches.
When you create your plan to achieve your desire,
do not base it on what you think is practical.
You reasoning faculty is lazy and we'll talk you out of taking action.
If your actual goal is to become a millionaire or to become a world champion
fighter,
you're reasoning faculty.
We'll see how much work it would take and it will talk you out of it by saying,
Oh,
you have to be more practical.
If you truly,
deeply want something,
you have to be able to vividly see yourself possessing it.
If you can't even imagine a world where it's possible,
how are you ever going to get it?
A good exercise is to ask yourself,
is there someone who is already accomplished what I want?
Most likely there is.
Then you have to ask yourself,
is there something special about them that I can't replicate or they just cut
from a different cloth?
In most cases,
the answer will be no.
In that case,
you can now try your best to replicate exactly what they did.
Yeah.
All great achievements are born from an idea.
Okay?
Every new success,
every new business,
every new invention has it.
Start in an idea.
Unfortunately,
we live in a world where most ideas get snuffed out before it can actually be
brought to life.
We get distracted and don't pursue it,
or we're told it's impractical or we're scared of what others will think of us.
Connor success started with an idea,
a desire that recognizing no such thing as failure.
Conor McGregor rose from humble beginnings to become one of the most influential
and highest paid fighters of all time.
He's able to do this because he had a definite purpose backed by a burning
desire that new no such thing as defeat.
He used auto suggestion to vividly imagine himself already in possession of
physical.
He created the most practical plans that he could and put them into action
immediately.
He kept his mind completely free of negative influences from countless people
who said it couldn't be done.
You have complete control of your state of mind.
Use it to ward off toxic negative influences.
Make a clear decision and burn the boats.
Cut off all forms of retreat,
develop the habit of persistence and do not stop three feet short of gold.
Nature has a way of rewarding those who persist when most would give up.
Hey guys,
thank you for watching and if you have an idea of someone you want me to do a
video on,
make sure you leave it in the comments below.